no that moves that carp off was so
unhappy with Queen e8 he felt this was a
critical error does the champion share
his opinion on this move Knight takes c6
so he did not see this move even I
didn't complain you like that it should
it should one I saw you playing very
quickly this it's just so civilized why
it's winning because it's I have seven
pieces in the attack to bishops tonight
two rooms and Brooks is detective queen
yes some pieces protected okay ooh two
pawns and Bishop and maybe Queen okay we
can't change you know it's it's liquid
equal change I change one attacking
peaceful one defense appeals but I have
enough pieces to make you so age six
well sis Reno's why didn't he take okay
if he takes here it's very nice I took
Knight takes d6 now I can show you many
good more interesting ways number one if
he's trying to escape new scheme going
in d7 did I put cool G fool if he takes
here then Bishop takes the seven eight
so Bishop takes you should explain takes
this is maddening if he takes if he
takes your Queens oh wait sir with and
check and he cannot because of his check
and this is spin the pawn is pinned and
the King gasa is amazing several moves
Bishop age seven Bishop d6 community
certainly if she takes my queen then
it's a very nice combination
check the only check check in the f7 you
should deception in g8
illness Bishop a5 usual b6 in the usual
things if I check and visual takes b7
and so you you have a nice investment
which is a rock up follow this
combination yes and but it's not it's
not the end of the story actually
Oh
this line I saw the board but somehow I
found after I just it proved that I was
right no this position you could go eh
wife you're up late oops you fight you
cannot take here because night of seven
check and take the Queen if you take
here it's interesting you know night a
track check English a roof XD 1 and C 3
it looks very good for black because
it's now the phone is closed Bishop is
hanging c2 is threatening but suddenly
night at 7:00 check in da Bishop d6 C
takes B to root page 5 and there is no
good answer
wonderful its mate again mate wonderful
its mate again so you had the feeling
for this position again and the final
final I can show you the final if you
sacrifice Queen I mean just in this
position if you sacrifice Queen but
playing Queen takes you 1 we takes one
route 86 then I played 24 mate 93 we
need for check King G Bishop to g7 you
should take the 7 in g4 and no defense
no rope cannot defend because in Texas
in this hole and this is over all the
pieces are disconnected absolutely and I
don't mean the carbon side but you
fellow this is bad she didn't take mine
it was confident in your calculations or
in your feeling maybe my feelings I was
just gonna try to to close this Bishop
you know it's fine but now this Bishop
is very strong City so first of all you
gave one piece now you're sacrificing
another PA another piece ok she killed
this bishop but this bishop now he
cannot close it anymore and he gave you
some Tempe which is important in chess
yes absolutely when I have ok I still
have six pieces so seven six instead of
seven this is not a big big loss no
there's no pony but one defender less as
you say before so instead of five now
for defend yes and it's nothing now okay
Bishop see a trying to to have some play
finish for check if you guys came jailed
and simply engage to and no defense in
95 95 and then queen edge
mate is trying to stop me eight-six take
engage two very strong more an important
move you know now my dad can go because
hanging without check 25 not g56 Lukey
eight now I have five only five pieces
intact but you know just through the
pendants left and it's just five very
poor so it was 7-5 6-4 and now five
three five three years five three years
anyway still the proportion is still 35
sweets is much more dangerous than than
seven five and for instance any move but
this should be seven here then it says I
have the same combination but Nate
immediately immediately he made the only
move just to avoid the mate in three but
anyway it's here I I play this very nice
man Queen takes the six this is
fantastic because in a world
championship it is very unusual to have
Queen sacrifices yes this is true we
take three six nine f7 shape in the
season here it's an unforgivable mistake
you know if yes a scissor oh yeah I know
but I wanted to take all his pieces you
know from the boards because after
uptake g-series me it would maple as him
just by removing the room here's a 97 97
visual takes a certain generic made here
checkmate because no square for the King
and it is mated with a bishop the
unfortunate this Bishop okay I took the
wizard piece win with the bishop and I
think the rest is just amazing
okay I have an ex rope again we are now
about to witness the magic of Garry
Kasparov
the world champion checks his
calculations it's really important to be
accurate at a time like this he has to
restrain himself clearly Kaz was very
excited here
one last check
no the incredible move Queen takes hate
six sacrificing the Queen the time
controls reached and Kasparov lens cap
off is scores you to copy up
and Karpov concedes what an incredible
game by Garry Kasparov
[Applause]